MARTIN OMANDER: Hello, and
welcome to "Root Access," the
show for startups on Google
Developers Live.
I'm Martin Omander, and I'm
joined here by legendary
investor and Googler,
Don Dodge.
Welcome, Don.
Today we're going to talk
about Demo Day season.
500 Startups and Y Combinator
two of the most well known
accelerators just had
their Demo Days.
And I know, Don, that you
attended both of them.
What trends did you notice
in the demos this year?
DON DODGE: More conservative.
More business focused.
In years past, you saw lots of
consumer oriented companies,
social kinds of applications,
and lots of mobile apps.
This year, it was more focused
on business, more
conservative, some might say
boring kinds of ideas.
But they make money.
So all of them, you could
clearly understand the
business model.
You can connect the dots from
where they are to a million or
so of revenue.
And more focused on business
as the customer.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
Was that a difference between
500 Startups and Y Combinator,
or what was the difference
that you noticed?
DON DODGE: No, both of them
were more business focused
than in the past.
I think the difference I saw
at 500 Startups was a more
international flavor.
So 500 Startups had about 32
companies, 35 companies.
And I would guess that half of
them were from countries all
over the world.
So a much more international
flavor from the founders, and
even the business ideas were
things that you wouldn't
normally think of as
being a business
opportunity in the US.
They were focused on those
sorts of things.
And generating revenue
pretty quickly.
Y Combinator was more Silicon
Valley focused.
The founders, who all seem to
come from Silicon Valley or
the other tech hubs, but again,
more business focused
and that kind of thing.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right, yeah.
I noticed that the Y Combinator,
a lot of those
startups, while they were
still in the accelerator
program were cash flow
positive already.
What's up with that?
DON DODGE: Well, I think when
you're focused on a business
to business kind of company,
you're selling to business,
businesses are more accustomed
to paying money for things.
As opposed to consumer oriented
companies, where
you're either generating revenue
based on advertising,
or on a subscription freemium
kind of thing, where it starts
out free and you pay
money later.
Those consumer web app kind of
social businesses take longer
to generate revenue.
Whereas business to business
type companies generate
revenue very early.
So many of the companies at Y
Combinator, they're launching
on stage and already talking
about revenue streams that
they have in place.
So I think that's the
major difference.
MARTIN OMANDER: I see.
How does all this play
into valuations?
Are the valuations higher,
lower, the
same as previous years?
DON DODGE: More reasonable,
I would say.
MARTIN OMANDER: Reasonable
That's good.
DON DODGE: In the past couple of
years, we were in a bubble
where companies just launching
at Y Combinator were having
valuations in the $8 to
$12 million range.
That's pretty rich for a company
with three or four
founders, and just launching
with negligible revenue to
have $8 to $12 million
valuations.
This year I think we saw the
valuations come down to more
reasonable levels, like in the
$7 to $10 million range.
So that's still pretty rich,
but down from the past two
years and a bit more
reasonable.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
Are these Silicon Valley
bubble valuations?
How are valuations in
Boston, Austin,
New York, other places?
DON DODGE: I think the
valuations in other
locations are lower.
So say more in the $4 to $7
million range than the $7 to
$10 million range that you
see in Silicon Valley.
There are, of course,
exceptions to that.
Great companies can start
anywhere and command very high
valuations.
But in general, Silicon Valley
investors are more accustomed
to paying up, and paying higher
valuations than in
other parts of the country or
in other parts of the world.
MARTIN OMANDER: So does that
mean that the good deals are
outside Silicon Valley?
DON DODGE: Well, it depends on
how you talk about good deals.
If you're talking about
valuation, yes.
Valuations are lower in other
parts of the country or
outside of the US.
But from an investor
perspective, a lot of times
valuation doesn't matter.
Because if a company hits it big
and goes to $800 million
valuation, it really doesn't
matter if you paid $5 million
or $8 million on the
first investment.
Conversely, if the company
fails, you lose 100% of your
money anyway.
So it doesn't matter if you
put your money in at $3
million or $8 million.
If you lose it all,
you lose it all.
So I think Silicon Valley
investors, in general, are
less valuation sensitive,
and look more
at what is the upside.
Because they know going in
they're going to lose half of
their money anyway.
Meaning half of the investments
they make will be
total wipeouts.
And the other half, one of them
hopefully will be that
$800 million or billion
dollar company.
And that pays for all
the mistakes.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, I see.
That's quite a bit different way
of managing money than I
manage my 401(k), I
can tell you that.
DON DODGE: Me too.
MARTIN OMANDER: Good.
That's all for today.
Please leave your comments
on the YouTube video, and
questions, and we'll
try to get back to
them in future episodes.
Thank you for joining us,
and see you next week.
Bye.